we begin in the US where the impeachment
inquiry into u.s. president Donald Trump
has resumed with a second day of public
hearings while today's session centers
on testimony from Murray
Jovanovic while the former US ambassador
to Ukraine was fired from her post in
Kiev after coming under attack by
Trump's personal lawyer Ruud of Giuliani
later she was branded bad news by Donald
Trump and in her opening statement
Jovanovic
said she had no agenda other than to
pursue the u.s. stated foreign policy
goals
take a listen individuals who apparently
felt stymied by our prep our efforts to
promote stated US policy against
corruption that is to do our mission
were able to successfully conduct a
campaign of disinformation against a
sitting ambassador using unofficial back
channels as various witnesses have
recounted they share baseless
allegations with the president and
convinced him to remove his ambassador
despite the fact that the State
Department fully understood that the
allegations were false and the sources
highly suspect our Ukraine policy has
been thrown into disarray and shady
interests the word of the world over
have learned how little it takes to
remove an American ambassador who does
not give them what they want
Murray Ivanovich speaking there in her
opening a statement let's take you now
to Capitol Hill to our correspondent
Public Foley ileus he is standing on
Capitol Hill Pablo first want to ask you
what struck you about her testimony I
think first and foremost Leyla really
you know the fact that it's been very
personal she hasn't held back whatsoever
you know she she was asked pretty
in-depth questions about her time there
in Ukraine and also some of her answers
were pretty you know shocking to many
people who were watching in fact one of
the the latest things that has happened
is that when she was asked about
president Trump's personal political
interests and also Joe Biden this you
know quid pro quo which we've heard as
so much mentioned it hasn't really been
mentioned so much
today but she said that at the time of
this phone call referring to the phone
call on July 25th which is the center of
all this
quid pro quo and she said that she
departed Ukraine two months prior and it
wouldn't have been in her policy in May
she said um and also she said do you do
they appear to you to benefit the
president's personal political interests
rather than the national interests she
responded with they could now at the
same time we've been seeing how
President Trump has been essentially
live tweeting quite intimidating at
tweets coming from him that's been
brought up in the hearing today and it's
been mentioned already right that is
extraordinary of course talk to us a
little bit more about that the president
weighing in in the middle of the
ambassador's testimony that's right now
a president Trump has essentially been
trying to a discredit you know at the
former US ambassador Murray Ivanovich
and of course you know Adam Schiff who
is there on one of the main people who's
asking these questions to Murray
Ivanovich has said that you know witness
intimidation is something that is taken
very seriously but you know President
Trump has been sort of saying that
anywhere that Murray Ivanovich went it
was essentially a disaster and trying to
justify in some way his decision to
bring her or to remove her from her
position there in Ukraine let's not
forget the Murray Ivanovich is a
long-standing a US diplomat with over
three decades of service so you know
it's a pretty dramatic start to this
second day of you know this these public
hearings extraordinary a development
reporting for you from Washington
Pablo Foley ileus thank you